meantime the Las Vegas massacre was the
latest in a long list of mass shootings
in the United States by one count there
have been more than a thousand since the
Sandy Hook killings in 2012 an estimated
93 people are killed by guns every day
in this country and now Democrats are
trying to restart the debate over gun
safety Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill
with why new laws may be difficult to
pass Nancy good morning good morning
those Democrats felt a surge of hope on
Tuesday when the president said that he
would be speaking about gun laws as time
goes by they're pushing in particular
for restrictions on the kind of
equipment that the shooter apparently
used to make his weapons even more
lethal at some point calling the Vegas
shooting a day of reckoning Democrats
urged the GOP to pick a policy any
policy is there nothing that we can do
among the options they say are bills to
mandate background checks prevent
stalkers from buying guns and banned
so-called bumped stocks which the Vegas
shooter may have used to increase the
rate of fire on his semi-automatic
weapons the only purpose to have one of
these devices is to see how quickly you
can kill a lot of people some
Republicans say they'd consider it
that's something I think that we'll take
a look at but others said this isn't the
time to talk policy I don't think we
should let assassin Senate Leader Mitch
McConnell was one of them I think it's a
premature to be discussing legislative
solutions if there are any House Speaker
Paul Ryan argue guns are not the main
problem what can you say to Americans
who just want to know how the body you
lead can make them more safe in the face
of shootings that seem to be getting
more frequent and more deadly one of the
things we've learned from these
shootings is that often underneath this
is a diagnosis of mental illness and
that's why the House Representative
passed landmark Mental Health Reform
just a year ago so then was it a mistake
to make it easier for mentally ill
people to get a gun Ryan later said
Congress rolled back that Obama era rule
blocking purchases by people with mental
illness because
infringed on the rights of legal gun
owners he did say the house now has no
imminent plans to vote on a bill to
allow the sale of guns silencers that
bill is not scheduled now I don't know
when it's going to be scheduled until
recently that bill appeared to be on the
fast track it is a big priority for the
National Rifle Association which
invested heavily in Republican
candidates in 2016 including the
president spending about 52 million
dollars almost triple what it spent in
2012 Charlie Nancy thanks